hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dungeon nightmares a
randomly generated indie horror game
that is supposedly excessively scary so
let's get into it
keep moving they know where you are
who's they do they need to know where I
am am i an important person in this
venture that's what I need to know and
now okay
it is dark I don't have a flashlight but
that says proceed to use and now it says
press B to blow really well if only life
was that easy but we can't always get
what we want you know help me it looked
like I got kind of a piece of paper what
the hell did I get who the hell am i
helping I'll help you
you know all I gotta do is press B to
blow if that helps you in any way that's
my one Oh what is this vanish
don't blow steam in my face okay I got a
map here ok well that's nice
at least it shows me exactly where I
went this candle doesn't do jack
doodly-squat I kept oh ah whatever it
was nothing okay I got the volume way
turned up in my headphones and I got my
pants way turned down on my legs I guess
if that made any sense and I'm ready to
go come on bring on the scares what is
that oh that's a fly is it it got flying
it's gonna buzz and burrow into my ear
like in that other game that I just
played don't let go
probably not okay I hear flies why would
there be flies unless they were dead
bodies just rotting openly in the floor
which there probably will be just say
just super see okay this is a dead end
but I'm gonna explore everything this
reminds me a lot of dread halls and I
apologize my voice is a little raspy
dude she's coming do I need to press B
to blow I'm just I'm curious if you need
me to because that's my one skill that's
the only thing I can do right now so uh
I got another candle that's good all my
candle went out I didn't even get to
blow it so these candles seriously do
not help me much at all can you run yes
I can run that's good that'll be useful
for running away like a big blob bubble
blowing baby candle Oh what no secret
message on that chest you told me
strange things on the other one okay
silence is good too right okay so uh
wolves that all about I like the
atmosphere in this game I've been pretty
lucky because there's been some good
horror ooh hi hey what are you just a
statue
hi I'm gonna call you boney you want me
to press B to blow you want me to press
B to ball blow boney okay what paper I
wouldn't look in the mirror where's a
mirror you dick bag mother humper ass
bag hole you just lost your beatable uh
privileges who's that was that someone
over there how am I supposed to finish
know what where to go skeleton oh he's
over there
he's a runnin oh there's the dead body
splayed out on the floor rotting for
everyone to see good okay alright yeah
someone complained about something over
there cuz I would like to say that my
problem seemed to be a bit more
significant than yours or maybe you're
being Myrtle eyes I don't know don't
trust anyone you meet down here alls
gonna trust boney I was about to be to
blow him but it didn't work out too well
cuz he was being a bit of a douche so
I'm gonna deed it
Dushan I'm just trying to make stupid
jokes that's all I do I'm just a dumb
youtuber plays video games to some
awesome fans probably the best fans in
the world
handsome and beautiful in every way nah
but seriously we just did 2.2 million
subscribers recently I'm gonna make a
vlog on Monday but you guys have been
absolutely amazing to me I mean that's
2.2 million after just hitting 2 million
about on a 2 and a half weeks ago the
growth has just been startling ly huge
and just thank you guys so much for
enjoying my videos I really do
appreciate it I didn't even read what
that said is there's nothing behind me
was that a guillotine going over my head
okay no all right come on I got places
to be I got things to do I'm out of
candles ah God I need more candles I'm
gonna run out very soon I'm going down
this place to the staircase hi steam I
was more worried about Bonnie over there
he the same bony as the other boney I
got to turn around open this door that's
interesting I was so hideously ugly that
the second I looked at him he died I was
so ugly everyone died maybe that's why
there's all these dead bodies I just
walked through everyone just died day
four it's so cold tonight need to find
more candles yes I agree it's about to
get darker in here not that the candles
do much but it's better than nothing
maybe it's not better than nothing
are you kidding me what the hell was
that
no you come back you you [ __ ] you don't
get away that easily you'll say that to
my face even though you did and you
sprayed your spit everywhere but I can
spray spit as an equal volume what is
this that's a book artifact found it was
a book not an artifact find the exit Wow
what do I do is it all the way down
there I'm gonna assume that it's all the
way at the end cuz that would be the
proper thing to do
stork am I going the right way
hey guy keep double-checking wow what is
that what am i why am i picking up gold
bars this is um this does remind me a
lot of dread halls maybe it's maybe it's
like this is dread halls but in a
different version of it cuz dry dolls
was originally why my turn why am i gay
guys why would who would hi you I'm
gonna stare at you till you die or I'm
gonna where I'm gonna near alright yeah
come on we serious here let's give you
Sue's here I'm almost out of can well I
really gotta get out of here you buy me
Wow wait a minute
I wanna see if like what is the
conditions in which these guys move
turning around oh hi okay that is the
Slenderman boys I recognize it you know
where I sleep you know I sleep in my bed
no how could you don't let her find you
her is that the glimpse of the someone
that I thought I oh oh okay
speeding up now come on come on come on
I'm almost at the exit I think are the
exit yeah yeah buddy
alright like get higher and higher I got
places me whoa oh that was a lot like
dread halls good new night one said
there were seven nights God how long is
this game gonna take two big you woke up
in six minutes and 50 seconds thank you
I know I'm great
Wow I found a lot of this stuff a very
surprised
let's see what night 2 is like cuz I'm
ready for another the dungeon grows
stronger well the first one wasn't very
strong to begin with so I don't know
about that
like two lates the surprising I there's
like usually with these experiences this
is like one done but let's go again
press space to start night two they only
move when you don't see them why cuz
they're embarrassed I would be okay
so night two things get stronger
supposedly don't follow her to that room
oh really
did she hear about my betta blow skills
she wants me to follow her too no no no
now you get at it with that noise come
on bring it up okay the atmosphere in
this game is great that's got some
really rock-solid jump scares I mean the
skeleton mechanic has been done before
but still it's not bad can't complain
and I really want to know what what's
with I only caught a glimpse of like
another person and I'm assuming that's
that lady they keep talking about okay
oh god this one looks fun and by fun I
mean horrible its EULA Julia died I
picked up a piece of paper and you tell
me to die isn't that a little extreme
here you want to explain what just
happened to me I laid II passed through
me and I felt a shudder down my spine
what was it what why was it am i
following her to that room
I don't think so I don't know so okay
okay that was a good one
doesn't good one this game has been ok
that's back dragon this game has been
pretty good with like keeping me on edge
and mixing things up I like it a lot
yeah like I said this was originally
developed for iOS I believe nothing in
there oh that's a nice painting another
cool back I sure I'm glad that I'm
focused on treasures in this time of
dire peril
I made a gold bar that size would be
like worth what a couple hundred
thousand dollars what why why why what
baby
what you do to me why why do I keep
blacking out you son of a [ __ ] sure
little dick bag
oh hi I didn't even know you were there
you get out of here you fall over and
die you douche bony I get it you don't
want me stealing your very good
treasures okay
okay she's still there she tell her
she's following me that's a dead end
like I'm owed I get I been open the damn
door who's he gonna get like a girl
night Wow
Oh God I'm in a dead end stop with the
noise the noise hold the door good God
will kill anybody what the hell who
house the most panic-inducing chase I've
had for a long time whoa Nellie
you need to tone it down this is only
night to this wait till we get to the
third date baby I'll let you get to
fifth base and score a home touchdown on
me if you know what I mean
oh that's me running out of Sprint juice
okay I get it I get it no I'm with it
I'm down to clown until we're all dead
in the ground which might be very very
soon here all right
hot hop was that steamed or was that
something else I have no idea
oh well there's the exit but what good
does that do me I don't have anything
for you scuse me can you shut up I am in
the middle of something I just got a
text I love you dear no no I know that
sound
well I don't know it but I know it means
bad hmm
I mean here I'm we're the sound I heard
was got something for me how am I gonna
find this damn artifact the darkness now
has you oh it does does it how does it
have me in one way oh no please darkness
don't get me oh no don't make me be to
blow if you know what I mean I think
everyone knows what I mean at this point
no one can hear you scream down there
I'm pretty sure hundreds of thousands of
people can hear me scream okay okay oh
oh hi Boni hey Boni you've lost your
privilege do you get out of here
is there anything else here Stephen okay
I'm gonna back out slowly this room go
this way I don't think there was a chest
in there but I may miss it
god I keep I keep running out of sprint
meet Ernest I need to concentrate in
focus I'm gonna beat this or else I'm
gonna die
those are my two options pretty much
where's Deb hi lady
oh you so pretty I'm out of candles
could you give me some I can't see a
damn thing
dead end all right let's get out of here
oh man I'm gonna have to loop all the
way back to the exit once I find this
ding dong Tam artifact listen he would
care about a book I got jump bars of
gold yeah you get out of here with that
noise now you get out of here with that
noise bang red light green
Hobson relight great night red light
green light
get up get out of here
you get out of here yeah yeah you're
real yeah and I rock Matt this isn't me
b2 blowing you you get out of here I'm
just moving you cuz I need to get to
this door go what's that you say
something okay
what's one no no I don't want any
company right now so you go eff off oh
he still wanted to PA but how'd you get
through that door handle now wait no I
got a candle ah now I'm gonna now you're
gonna get it now you might get it I
don't know I'm looking in the chest for
the artifact it was a on a shelf before
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you get out of
here ba
I have fun at school and he'll have fun
in hell school you know what I made
Tommy a subtle either go to hell God
where is this thing oh I found it
yay I can move on now let's get out of
here oh come on stop sprinting for two
meters and then dying of breath loss
okay so if I go straight down here
slightly to the right you know that red
text when it says artifact this fan
makes me think that I might die soon I
might die soon
no thank you
I need some personal space if you don't
mind Oh ki dokie another I'm so out of
here
I'm not down to clown with you
don't sprint so much calmly walk there's
no crisis oh why is there crisis where's
our crisis know why suddenly it was
their crisis wherever I'm going the
wrong way no I'm on the right way love
it some pepper no bad time to run out of
Sprint I'm gonna be to blow you and then
I'm gonna get out of here we all right
you son of a [ __ ] okay there you have
it nay to survive yeah it makes me
wonder cuz there are five more nights
how am I gonna do this like this is
getting a bit more complicated I wonder
I wonder I wonder if I should do a
second part of this mmm alright okay
I'll do it this way cuz it's been I've
been playing for about 70 minutes
there's no way I'm gonna get through all
seven they want our revenge well they
can come get a piece of me later if you
guys want it so either way leave a like
to let me know if you want me to
complete three su-7 there's actually not
a bad horror game here it's actually
kind of fun I wonder what new and
interesting stuff awaits me on the other
nights but either way
laia write a comment leave a like thank
you all so much for watching and also I
don't know if I've ever mentioned it but
if you guys want to please follow me on
Facebook and Twitter there links and
down in the description you can keep up
to date on other stuff that's going on
like secret projects I'm working with
with collabing with other people and
live streams that go on in the in the
darkness that you guys don't already
know about so either way just give me a
follower like if you want to thank you
all so much for watching and as always I
won't see you in the next video
ba-bye oh my god it's terrifying Oh